Michael I've learned you since you were
a child you've a gift
you always have if there's an answer to
the disease we'll find it
I should have died years ago
why am I still here if not to fix this I
have a rare blood disease and I'm not
that at a time
this could be my last chance
you're up to something what is it
that's not exactly label
now I want to see you get hurt more than
you already have this would be a cure
at what cost
it's happening I went from time
[Music]
of increased strength and speed
the ability to use echolocation
overpowering earth to consume blood
[Music]
how far are we allowed to go
we'll fix something that's broken
until the remedy
is worse than the disease
[Music]
Michael Morbius at I'm doing a little
good guy thing up what's up guy welcome
back everyone is Charlie this is gonna
be my Morbius trailer breakdown what
universe are we in because we have
spider-man and we have the vulture in
this movie so we had a lot of stuff to
talk about and it all seems like it's in
service of a big sinister six team-up
eventually if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
easter-egg videos we're doing a movie
ticket giveaway - all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
biggest theory about that big cameo
during the trailer so I know everybody's
wondering what's the deal with
spider-man showing up with the murderer
graffiti behind him in the prison garb
as he's walking by this is all happening
in New York City as you can see from a
lot of the other shots in the trailer
the flashbacks also take place in New
York City and then also Michael Keaton's
vulture characters shows up at the end
of the trailer looking like he just
broke out of prison because he's
bringing the exact same outfit that he
was during the spider-man homecoming
post-credits scene totally mind-blowing
and on top of that the picture of
spider-man on the wall there with
murderer that seems like it's meant to
imply the events of spider-man far from
home like everyone thinks that he killed
Mysterio so they think of him as a
murderer you'll notice that the costume
isn't the MCU Tom Holland costume that
he ends in spider-man far from home it's
actually the Tobey Maguire era
spider-man costume in the picture itself
is based on the spider-man ps4 game it's
literally like a screen cap that they
took at a spider-man ps4 so either
someone is just messing with us a little
bit or they're just mixing and matching
a whole lot of elements from MCU Tom
Hollands spider-man stuff in the new
Sony venom verse we knew they were gonna
cross Tom Holland over into the venom
movies eventually this just seems like
it's all in service of that eventual
crossover happening way sooner than we
ever expected I wouldn't be surprised if
he actually does show up in venom 2 at
some point but talking about the actual
Morbius footage most of you are probably
stay little familiar with the Morbius
character he was basically Marvel's
attempt to do something based on the
Dracula character the funny thing is is
that Dracula already is a Marvel comic
book character but they wanted to create
a new character so way back in the 1970s
when the Dracula craze around the world
got really really popular
they created the Morbius character and
he's not technically a vampire the way
the
Dracula's a vampire he doesn't get his
abilities through a vampire bite even
though there are a lot of vampire bats
flying around in the trailer they kind
of do their version of the comic book
origin story there's a couple minor
changes but a lot of Easter eggs for the
original version of his origin story the
person it seems like Jared Harris is
playing is actually a version of his
original partner in the comics so in the
comics Morbius is the biological
scientist he has a rare blood condition
just like he talks about during the
trailer he's slowly been dying for a
long time his time is running out but
the testing that he needs to perform on
himself isn't totally legal so they go
out into international waters like where
you see them go to this special cave
with the helicopter that's their version
of doing that in the comics it was a
boat that they went out to on
international waters
Morbius performs a special treatment
using electroshock therapy in the blood
of vampire bats mixed with his own blood
that causes the accident that gives him
his powers as basically was playing out
during the trailer here and then because
Jared Harris is sort of this father
figure to him as he says I've known you
since you were a boy and he also seems
like he was a doctor and inspired
Morbius to eventually become a doctor
himself when he grew up in the comics
when he's on that boat with his research
partner and his girlfriend martine
Bancroft who's played by this woman in
the trailer he's immediately driven to
feed through his vampire urges and he
accidentally attacks his research
partner so it seems like this footage in
the trailer is him actually attacking
Jared Harris and accidentally killing
him without realizing what's going on
like he's using these abilities to jump
around this New York City apartment and
then it jumps on this person you can't
quite see what's going on but then he
screams out in pain so this might be him
accidentally killing Jared Harris right
after he gets his abilities because you
see the montage of the trailer where he
slowly starts to get better but then
they find out that he's starting to turn
into something of a vampire himself like
they put him behind the glass and he
starts punching it so he probably tries
to isolate himself early in the process
while they're figuring out what it is
that's happening to him if you're a big
comic book reader you also probably
notice the other part of his origin
story - with this oil tanker in the
comics after he accidentally kills his
research partner he throws himself
overboard so that he won't be consumed
to feed on his girlfriend Martine
Bancroft
but his survival instincts as a vampire
kick in save him and then he gets
rescued out of the water by this boat of
fishermen he winds up feeding on all
so you see him flying around this oil
tanker boat killing all these people
that's probably their version of that
from the comics Matt Smith is playing
the locust crown character so he might
wind up becoming the villain sometime
later in the trailer - it's not really
clear what he's doing in the course of
this trailer footage though because you
just see Emma what seems like the subway
platform walking around going somewhere
else
in the comics he had the same rare type
of condition that Morbius had that was
killing him he went through a similar
type of treatment it also got a bunch of
powers but wound up being super super
evil Morbius as you can see from the
trailer is actually getting the venom
treatment as an anti hero inside this
Sony venom burst and now it looks like
connected to the spider-man MCU universe
as well the smokey looking special
effects behind him when he's flying
around using his vampire abilities
remind me a little bit of the special
effects they use for the Nightcrawler
character during x-2 in the original
x-men films the rest of the trailer is
mostly a montage of action scenes just
letting you know what his abilities look
like it's really just meant to be the
teaser trailer and obviously just give
you the big bomb oh my god this is
happening inside the spider-man universe
and we have Michael Keaton as the
vulture coming back from spider-man
homecoming my guess is when we get to
the next trailer there'll be a little
bit more of the story and they'll reveal
a little bit more about what's going on
with the villain because locust crown is
meant to be sort of the carnage for the
Morbius character like venom is meant to
be the anti-hero the venom movies even
though technically he's a spider-man
villain but then along comes someone
who's even worse that he has to take
down so Loki's crown is that for the
Morbius character like I said I'm not
sure why they're using the Sam Raimi
spider-man costume but this is meant to
be taking place after the spider-man far
from home post-credits scene so the
world thinks that he killed Mysterio
thanks to Jay Jones Jameson in that
footage that Mysterio concocted also I
kind of think that there's gonna be a J
Joe to Jameson cameo during this there
was a rumor that I talked about in my
last Morbius teaser video now I'm
actually starting to believe it because
Michael Keaton just showed up and we got
confirmation on this spider-man Easter
egg the other really big actor that's in
this is Tyrese it just seems like he's
one of the feds who's coming for Morbius
and then finds out that eventually
during the course of the movie that he's
not evil there's someone that's even
worse the Loach's crown character and
maybe they wind up teaming up to take
them down Tyrese also signed a multi
picture deal so whatever big team up
that Morbius
with venom whatever maximum carnage
storyline that they have with spider-man
Tyrese will also be part of that too
then at the end of the trailer they gave
you the full-on Morbius treatment this
is what he'll look like when he's in
full vampire form so maybe for this
version of the movie they're gonna allow
him to transform back and forth between
his more human looking form and the
vampire form in the comics for the most
part he's locked into this one form
until he finds a treatment that
eventually cures him and then he
eventually gets his powers back I know a
lot of you were wondering if they're
gonna do this special spider-man
storyline where he gets the multiple
arms because that's the story line that
Morbius debuted during in the spider-man
comics amazing spider-man back during
the early 1970s I don't think that Tom
Holland is gonna show up in this movie
with six arms that would just be
completely weird but it would be funny
if there was an Easter Egg for that
somewhere during the movie the whole
thing about his introduction in the
comics is that it's actually part of a
Spider Man lizard story with Curt
Connors they're both looking for
something to cure their condition and
they find that Morbius his blood will do
that so Morbius is more of a villain
when he shows up in the spider-man
comics for the first time but eventually
it's a very venom movie type of twist
where he's like I'm only going to feed
on people that are bad I'm only gonna
hurt people that are evil as far as the
Michael Keaton vulture cameo it does
look like he just broke out of prison
because he's wearing the exact same
outfit so I don't know what Morbius is
doing in this prison outfit either
because he's wearing a completely
different prison uniform but the line of
dialogue ah so you got tired of doing
the whole good guy thing makes it sound
like maybe he breaks a bunch of people
out of prison himself I was a little
upset that we didn't get a follow up to
the spider-man homecoming post-credits
scene during spider-man far from home
but it seems like they were saving that
for the Morbius movie in this venom
verse tying it all together it does seem
like it's all in service of a sinister
six team up movie however they're going
to accomplish that remember that Sony is
also developing a craven movie for the
Kraven character and there is a craven
truck that shows up somewhere during the
Morbius movie this is actually screen
grabbed from behind the scenes while
they were shooting so regardless of when
that sinister six movie is going to
happen they are definitely setting that
up in this movie let me know in the
comments though we all kind of figured
that they would head for a maximum
carnage team-up because of the venom
movies but do you actually think that
they're gonna get two sinister sticks
faster than they get to maximum carnage
or do you think
can I do maximum carnage at all and
they'll just go straight to sinister six
I think when they announced the Morbius
movie most people were like why are they
doing Morbius I don't understand he's
not that big of a character now
everyone's heads have turned around and
they're like you had my curiosity but
now you have my attention so I feel like
a bunch of people are just gonna show up
just to see how this is connected to the
MCU version of spider-man and Tom
Holland for now my expectations are that
Tom Holland does not appear himself in
this movie maybe they use some stock
footage from the end of spider-man far
from home but for the most part I think
that they're very light touches when it
comes to physical actual spider-man
appearing and some of this stuff I would
be a little bummed out if Tom Holland
appeared physically in the Morbius movie
before he appeared in a venom crossover
so I think that they're still
negotiating to get him into venom 2 and
some sort of post credits scene or
something like that but the cool thing
is is that venom 2 is coming out in
October so we'll probably it the first
trailer for that when the Morbius movie
comes out this summer the Morbius movie
is being released right after Comic Con
so we're not gonna have to wait that
long to find out what's going on with
venom and carnage they'll probably drop
some early teasers before that - so
everyone post your theories in the
comments below I'll name a giveaway
winner the next time I post a Marvel
video let me know in the comments if
they're any big follow-up videos that
you want me to do based on the Easter
eggs and this and all the spider-man
stuff while you wait for everything
click here for that brand new Iron Man
announcement video and click here for my
brand-new Deadpool 3 video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight